[Music]
joining me is an evolutionary biologist
formerly of Evergreen State University
who is now a professional professor in
exile Heather hi and welcome to the
Reuben report thank you for having us
dance professor in exile I believe that
is in your Twitter bio it is I believe
it is in your husband Brett Weinstein's
Twitter bio yeah we generated just
together is that gonna be the title of
the co-authored book when the dust
settles on all of this stuff oh I don't
know I think both of us are both eager
to leave the Evergreen story behind but
still heartbroken that an institution
that we loved and still believe in the
educational model that it offered and
still believed in the students who got
great education was there for many
decades we we would love to see it
resurrected but it doesn't look like
it's gonna happen yeah all right so this
is it's a little crazy to me that this
is the first time that we've met because
obviously our circles have been sort of
closing in on each other for for quite
some time so when when the whole
Evergreen thing happened and I only want
to spend a little bit of time at the top
talking about and then I want to do all
sorts of evolutionary biology stuff and
the other the other things that you're
really passionate about the story
obviously was more focused on Brett and
then he was sort of thrust into the
media and all that but this was a direct
attack on you as well and as you said
the institution that you loved and all
that can you just give me any sort of
recap or just pieces of it that maybe we
don't know that well or just her
perspective on what was happening there
well as briefly as I can leaving out
many many relevant pieces we got a new
president and the new president very
quickly got rid of a Provost who was
going to get in his way and spoke
publicly about his desire to turn
evergreen into the social justice
college that was actually on the record
early in George bridges tenure at the
point that the protests broke out a year
ago
now-ish he had been president for about
two years and a year before that had
broken out in equity
a desire to bring equity and inclusion
to the forefront which is which is
codewords it's dog whistles for the
people on the far left who are actually
interested in a reversal of power not an
end to oppression but an actual reversal
of historical oppression did you guys
recognize those things as dog whistles
at the time because as Brett said at the
time he considers himself or at least at
that time did consider himself deeply
progressive you just said to me right
before we started you still consider
yourself progressive yeah so did you
realize those buzz words and and what
they actually meant at the time
absolutely
I mean Brett actually I was on
sabbatical that you're most of the year
before this broke out is murder and why
I was disappeared from the story I said
as I went onto sabbatical Brett I will
continue to read everything you want to
send out to these lists but I am not
engaging I am doing my own work now so
about a year actually a year to the day
before the protests broke out the first
announcement of the new plan came came
live and then and there and for the next
year Brett was I was a little bit a
couple of other people who are a little
bit standing up and saying this doesn't
smell right this this feels like this is
actually about something that we're not
talking about and furthermore if we are
actually interested in improving the
fate of various demographic groups these
processes are not going to be the way to
accomplish them so we were saying that
Bret mostly was saying that a few others
of us were saying it and was there any
sort of understanding of that point of
view privately yes
privately yes people were scared and
when in fact when Brett used the phrase
culture of fear on campus what came back
at him was you have to prove that
there's a culture of fear or else
there's not one and you know show me the
people who aren't standing up or else I
will know that they they don't exist
which is you know it's baffling yeah
right it's it is obviously an improve an
unprovable statement to say there's a
culture of fear and I'm not going to out
the people who have come to me
they're scared as I actually am going to
honor their privacy but if if everyone
who had come to us privately and said
this is nuts and it's got to stop
had stood up it would have been a
totally different outcome well that's
the culture of fear summed up right
there right okay so without rehashing
the whole thing can you just tell me a
little bit about sort of how your life
has changed throughout this and sort of
you know look you and Bret you guys did
settle it wasn't for a ton of money at
least in my humble estimation but I
think you probably wanted to just put
some of this behind you but you guys are
professors and I saw you if you have
kids and family and all that stuff and
just sort of sum up kind of where you're
at at the moment yeah so I mean we had
we've been living in Olympia for 15
years the the college was an amazing
place to really do a deep dive in
community with students and so you know
Bret and I had done one and I had done
several long study abroad trips in
Panama and in Ecuador with pretty large
groups of undergraduates taking them
through the Amazon through Galapagos we
spent time in the field in Washington
State in the San Juans in Eastern
Washington took people places where not
only we were studying evolutionary
biology and animal behavior and field
techniques and statistics of the
philosophy of science but also coming to
know each other such that after you
after you break bread with people for
days and you play ultimate with them and
you sit around a campfire you come to
understand that when they disagree with
you it's not inherently coming from a
place of hatred or personal animosity
and so that trust that we were able to
create in our classrooms which both of
us love to doing allowed us to
effectively then rip the intellectual
rug out from under people when they made
claims that weren't falsifiable or
couldn't be it couldn't be justified
once you started to ask them what the
assumptions were they were underlying
their claims that was that was an
amazing gift and I don't know that
really almost any other educational
model out there allows for that because
it required the time to build community
with students which was which was
wonderful so yes we lost to tenure track
jobs along with our health insurance and
our retirement plans and all of that and
have two kids still in school so that's
alarming
but some of what we were doing in the
classroom we have begun to do on larger
stages and that is promising it seems
clear that the world is interested in
hearing how to understand systems from
an evolutionary perspective I knew that
was true from the 25 or 50 students that
I had doing the deep dive for every
quarter every year for years it's not
that surprising but it is heartening to
see that that is the response of many
many people out there in a weird way
does it almost feel right then that this
happened I mean I know it's kind of
sucky and again with the salaries and
tenure-track positions and all that but
that the message that you guys are
talking about seems so relevant right
now you guys are now doing more public
speaking gigs I'm dragging Brett on
stage with me to do stand-up and all
sorts of crazy things are presenting
themselves and then the sort of the rise
of this new alliance of whether you want
to call it intellectual dark web or
whatever you want to call it at this
point but there is this sort of
interesting crew of people with a lot of
different feelings on a lot of different
issues with all sorts of different
disciplines coming together and maybe if
you guys were still at university in a
traditional sense you wouldn't be able
to be dealt in the way that you are now
I think that's possible I think there is
both a way in which having gone through
the looking-glass having gone through
the direct you know to borrow a phrase
from the far left but the lived
experience of actually being at the
center of a mob at the center of riots
and then watching as the world the
mainstream media and others tried to do
a public relations spin on it and tell a
totally different story
to live that and to watch the
institution that you love to become
totally disloyal to you and to watch
many people whom you respected hide you
can't don't see that it's valuable and
the fact that we're sitting here talking
together and that many of us in you know
the intellectual dark web and in this in
this bigger group are are speaking and
saying actually the culture of fear that
is society-wide
is real and so I'll say the the first
time I met my students after
November 2016 election after Trump was
selected evergreen it's a very left
place Olympia is a very left place
pretty much everyone on campus had that
glazed eyes slack-jawed look that people
in most progressive enclaves will be
familiar with from that time from those
few days right
myself included even though I was no
Hillary fan but I didn't see that
outcome coming and I certainly didn't
vote for Trump I am we got to class and
my co faculty whom I admire greatly just
preceded with her lecture on horse
evolution and I'm looking around the
classroom going no one here cares about
horse so she ended a bit early and we
had lab a couple hours later and before
she let them go I said hold on if anyone
wants to stay this is no longer class
but if anyone wants to stay I would be
happy to lead a conversation about what
just happened yeah what just happened to
our country and about 40 of our 50
students stayed well skip their lunch
hour again we went right to anatomy lab
that afternoon from from this
conversation and what I said to them was
do not for a minute believe that racists
and sexist elected Trump think about how
many times you have had to censor
yourself on this campus when you had an
opinion that was even slightly different
from the accepted dogma and that
conversation not only brought life to
the room but afterwards I had several
students come up to me some of them in
tears telling me stories about one of
them had lost a job on campus for
speaking an opinion that was not
accepted one of them had an another
story of another friend who'd lost a job
others talked about their self
censorship and that and all of these
people again were for left not that it
should matter but these work even people
who were conservatives or who held
conservative views so that that is the
larger culture of fear that is hardly
restricted to Evergreen but is
society-wide that we are that we are
speaking about and that people are
responding to because in you know at
Google at Starbucks in cubicles in
campuses but far beyond campuses
the country and across the weird country
is at least this is a problem well the
irony to me is that I think that all
that I'm doing is talking about these
things often with people who have a much
better
pedigree than I do but by me talking
about it it's giving room for other
people to talk about that's all that
they want well you're also you oh you
are also providing ways into the
conversation I think so there are a lot
of people when confronted with you're
not allowed to think that say oh god I'm
not actually sure how to respond I
haven't I don't know I don't I don't
have the linguistic skills I don't have
the analytics behind me I don't know
what I'm supposed to say here and so
just listening to to you and to sam
Harris and the Jordan Peterson and to
Brett and to Eric and to me and to know
many many others I believe begins to
give people a sense of not only is this
doable these are good reasonable smart
people who are being respectful and what
they're saying but also it's not just
tools it's actually like freezes it's
you know this is what you can say these
are the things that sort of things that
you can say in response that are still
respectful and don't reject the humanity
of the person on the other side but do
reject the argument it's interesting it
almost shows that what you guys
obviously were doing so well at a
university level that's exactly what's
needed at a societal level now talking
about the language the language to get
these ideas across is so important I
wonder is there a evolutionary
explanation for a little bit of what has
happened here with the left like the way
they've sort of closed off ranks and
then purged everyone because it's just
as I sit here with you it's like the
idea that you and Brett wouldn't be
enough of whatever it is that they want
is so bananas and yet it is true so is
there some way that you can explain that
coming from the discipline you come from
well there's I think this is not going
to be a particularly deep point but it's
it's basic in-group out-group dynamics
and we will always we will not get rid
of of tribal thinking we will not get
rid of our sense of you know you and I
are aligned right that's that's a good
thing there's a way in which there's a
kind of tribalism there even though we
just met for the first time today you're
not and
and we definitely have political
differences and I'm sure which we can
talk about if we won't happen right so
we end but but that isn't the main thing
like we're aligned and I you know I feel
walking in here like you've got my back
and you've got my back and I think
people especially raised without much
experience with the physical world and
raised often in situations where they're
being given a number of pharmaceuticals
early on that are disrupting development
arrive at what should be the cusp of
adulthood and aren't sure how to
navigate aren't sure how to navigate the
waters and so when told oh if you just
agree with everything if you just become
an ideologue and go in lockstep with us
you can be with us so you know identity
politics is appealing because it
provides an instant in-group if you will
only subjugate yourself yeah and you
know identity politics on this side
begets at Annie politics on this side of
course because anyone who shows up here
and is told no you don't have enough of
what the progressive stack tells us you
need either you can totally subjugate
yourself or go over there well of course
we're going to get a rise over here and
back and forth when people criticize us
whoever this is for not focusing on that
identity politics enough the the one
that the secondary one that you're
talking about here which is the identity
politics of the right which is either
which is based in actual racism or or
you know there's a white at no state or
ideas that are so the antithesis of the
American experiment it to me they're
they're ridiculous and have no real
real-world traction it's almost like
we've created this bogeyman because we
need it they've long since been just
like what no no almost no one thinks
that way anymore sorry no well so what's
your what's your best argument against
that well people say well you're not
focusing on that enough because because
everyone wants everything to be equal
all the time so if you're focusing on
the identity politics the left which
clearly many of us see is I mean I truly
see it I've been saying this and I
really believe this I view it as the
greatest existential threat to Western
democracy that there is I believe that
if there's something that would cause us
to be on the streets like killing each
other I think it's that we're will have
broken off and all of the commonalities
will disappear but what what do you
is the best argument for what you're not
focusing on that one enough because I
see that a lot now right I think I think
two things one it's not as big a group
right the the white nationalists to the
extent that they exist and they do are
better armed by and large than than the
far left but numerically they just don't
exist in the same numbers and they don't
have the kind of play they don't have
the kind of cultural reach that the far
left does and so that's the second well
I guess there's three points a secondary
point then is everyone can walk white
nationalists that is completely
acceptable and in fact demanded that you
do when those sorts of ideas come up in
conversation whereas the stuff on the
far left increasingly it is demanded
that you not using so there is that's a
key right there right so like we are
saying no actually we must we must
disagree with this just as much as we
should just as much as culturally we now
know it's a norm to disagree with what's
on the right we the far right it should
become a cultural norm to disagree with
frankly the cryptic racism and sexism
and you know and everything else that's
happening on the far left it is it comes
packaged as if it's anti-racist and
anti-sexist and all it's just it's
racist and sexist against the other
group it's it's a flipping of the the
tables of oppression so I would say the
third point is for me anyway as someone
who has been on the left my whole life
this has changed this experience is
going through the looking-glass in the
last year has not changed my values but
it has changed what I understand about
how people are using language to make
other people out to be things they're
not yeah so you know I no longer believe
in a massive alt right for instance
right right and you know the the boogie
men that are out there that you're not
supposed to do things like talk to Fox
News
mmm-hmm sorry no actually we should all
be exposing ourselves to to the media
across the entire range and for me on
the left it's actually my job much more
so than to go after people who I have
nothing in common with
to go after the people who claim to have
values that are similar to mine but I
see that they are actually achieving
goals that are different yeah and that's
why I love this conversation and I don't
get tired of it because we're all in on
it
at different levels we all have
different realizations at different
times along the timeline and it's like
for me that's where I'm free for two
years I kept saying I'm of the left and
that's why I want to fix this
I don't think realistically anymore I
can honestly say that I think I have
more in common certainly with
libertarians and I find him I find an
intellectual openness with conservatives
that I just don't find any more on this
other side and I know there's yet I know
there's some people you just spoke at
heterodox yeah you just spoke at
heterodox Jonathan hates been on the
show I think he's doing wonderful work
there's obviously people like Brett and
like Eric and and Steven Pinker and
plenty and Sam and plenty of other that
exists still as sort of a sane left but
I see that just being whittled and
whittled and whittled away and that
doesn't mean the fights not worth taking
it maybe it means it's the most worthy
fight but I just see it as like an
increasingly untenable position to hold
I think I think there are actually many
many many people out there who are not
who don't have public platforms who are
waiting who've been waiting for this
yeah who are watching you most of these
people would consider themselves
Democrats as I always did I don't I
don't want to identify as a Democrat
anymore given what they now stand for
but most I think that and this you know
as evidenced by my inbox so it was
anecdotal but it's a lot of Anna yes and
you know and also my Twitter feed that
there are a massive number of people out
there who are on the Left who have
values on the left and who find no one
out there who was making sense except
now except this girl emerge yeah yeah
and it it has taken it has taken this -
you have this fever-pitch that we have
arrived at for a number of people I
really think and like I said you know
Google Starbucks but it's not just those
big stories there are people writing to
me and to Brett from just average
workplaces saying I'm in fear for my job
because I
cannot speak anything that doesn't fit
the dogma we just hired an equity
advisor we've just hired an inclusion
advisor and it's and it's hateful it's
hateful rhetoric that we are being told
to adopt this is what's happening across
corporate America now of course most
Americans are not going to appreciate
that yeah it's like it existed at the
universities for a long time and finally
it started bubbling out of there and
those kids took those ideas and started
entering the workforce that's why it's
so worried you know people say you're
all you're focusing on college students
too much and it's like you do realize
they get out of college that's usually
right so tell me a little bit more about
sort of what you're doing now I know you
just spoke at heterodox and all right
let's start let's start with that
heterodox yeah yeah well the this was
heterodox Academy's first conference
they and fire are really at the
forefront institutionally of defending
viewpoint diversity on campuses fire
from more of a legal perspective and
heterodox at the faculty administrative
perspective and it was point was an
intense conference it's the only
conference I've ever been to where I
thought this should have been longer all
academics in the audience as well or do
they open that up there I think the
public eye I think there were probably
not academics there I know there were a
lot of journalists there and most
everyone I met were students or faculty
or admin or journalists so I don't know
I don't know what the what the entry
rules were but you know the panels were
as as Jonathan Hyde said at the end of
the day I Jonathan count only three
people who were on the panel's of I
guess twenty eight people who might be
conservative so he himself pointed out
you know we're striving for a few point
diversity but the fact is it's an uphill
battle you know we're not going to get
just just like we shouldn't expect a
50:50 sex ratio among soft software
engineers between men and women we're
not going to get a 50/50 ratio of
liberals and conservatives on college
campuses it's not necessarily the kind
of work the conservatives flock to in
the same numbers as liberals do so I
think you know we need to be careful
about imagining what what equity would
look like as in all of these argument
and at an idea level why would it be
that conservatives would be less
inclined to be doing academics I guess
it depends on what our definition of
conservative is one of a stereotype that
comes to mind that I may regret saying
is that liberal types take some odd
pride and not caring about making a good
living good money faculty positions tend
to tend to fit that right certainly
evergreen did so you know if you if what
if one of your primary goals is not only
to make a good living for yourself but
potentially to leap out of the living
your making and you know really hit it
big you're unlikely to do that in
academia so there's a there's a sort of
a risk aversion I think to the prospect
of making it big financially that
academics tend to have that maybe maybe
conservatives would be less likely to go
that way do you think it could also be
that conservatives were just
self-selecting out like they realized
that hostile atmosphere so they were
just like why would I do this absolutely
that is one of the explanations for sure
and you know certainly in some fields
you know an engineer the the less human
focused the field the more conservatives
there are we know this so in engineering
for instance in the more physical
sciences mostly people don't speak their
politics on college campuses if they are
on the right because they're not welcome
there but but those fields do have
higher representations of conservatives
than liberals but most of the social
sciences and Humanities were always
tended liberal but are even more so I
don't remember the numbers off the top
of my head but even more so now than
they ever have been and that's a problem
to have you know take you know to have a
field that is trying to understand the
nature of humans in any of the social
sciences psychology or anthropology or
sociology to be entirely limited to
people on the left side of the political
spectrum maybe you're missing something
in your explanation of what humans are
if you don't have anyone who's willing
to speak to a different political
position
so when I've talked to Jordan Peterson
who you referenced and my friend Peter
Bogosian and a couple other people who
are professors are you probably know
Pete
I think a lot of their argument is based
around that you know gender studies and
these sort of these sort of new fields
basically have a completely separate set
of standards that have virtually nothing
to do with any of the standards that you
as an evolutionary biologist had to add
to and have to prescribe to to do your
work is that really the crux of it sort
of at the institutional level high
schools I that is at least one of the
foci that I have seen as well that there
are many new fields many of which end in
the word studies like gender studies
that are right there they're made up
they are based in post-modernism and not
just not just post-modernism because
about its base originally there there's
some stuff of value there believe it or
not but the the new manifestations in
critical theory and such are are
basically free of any fact-checking
apparatus so they are they are anti
science they are from anti-enlightenment
and and they're quite willing to say
things like reason is a tool of the
patriarchy
yeah this is the new one this one
started popping up in the last six
months right and I mean you just have to
know you're dealing with people who are
not going to be playing in good faith
and willing to have an actually viable
argument at the point that they say that
so it's that there has been capture you
know pretty pretty solid capture and a
few of the more traditional fields not
entirely in fact I met several people at
heterodox who are sociologists who are
fighting this from within but sociology
is one of the captured fields in
anthropology geography and cultural
anthropology in particular so that the
fact that it is that there are fields
that students can go into and basically
never be exposed to the idea of you're
going to generate as many possible
explanations for the thing that you've
observed as possible we're going to
hypothesis generation first and then
we're going to try to figure out what
would have to be true if any if each of
those individual hypotheses were true
and then we're going to try to figure
out how to test between them that's the
scientific method and it's it's
inefficient it sometimes gets things
wrong but it is the only tool we have to
over time get to a better and better
understanding of the universe and
there's there's no there's a method yeah
over in gender studies yeah so how have
you seen that way of thinking leaked
into the harder sciences because this
seems to be the next frontier here yeah
there are there are some schools now
that when positions come open in in
science disciplines so muted most
schools this wasn't you at Evergreen but
at most schools sort of the hiring
apparatuses within within Department so
you know if someone in physics retires
and physics gets to decide the physics
faculty and department chair and such
get to decide what kind of physicists
they're going to hire next somehow
increasingly science educators are being
as being hired
rather than scientists themselves and
science educator is a code word for
people coming out of ed schools and
education schools have have this
pathogen mmm-hmm very very badly so
science educators being hired into
positions that should have been
scientists means that now you have a
weakening of scientific voice in
scientific method in science departments
hmm you have a I mean even I was it just
recently nature I think published you
know one of the two big science journals
published I don't worry if it was a
letter or an article arguing that one of
the primary things that science needs to
be focusing on is increasing diversity I
surface so you know two problems with
this
what are your measures of diversity it's
the stuff that you can see on first pass
it's these immutable characteristics and
has nothing to do with actually all the
other kinds of diversity that are
interesting and that you know and and
that we can change things like political
belief and you know some things that we
can't change but things like being on
the autism
spectrum or you know even like you know
colorblindness or dyslexia or left
handedness all of which provide your
brain without us ever being conscious of
it some different way of approaching the
world and that kind of diversity in a
group of people ads ads actual intrigue
and nuance to conversations I'm a lefty
with a little dyslexia so lefty is like
you know like many other members of
these groups but I happen to happen to
know the lefty one because I've done
some research on it lefties are over
represented at you know in the National
Academy of Sciences and in mental
institutions I've got this really big
spread well now I can see that there's
really two options for your future
that's right
[Music]